what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so initially I wanted to cover the
story of the molecule man destroying
Thor's hammer and I do have it uploaded
onto my channel I might go ahead and
release that I have no earthly clue but
the more I thought about it the more I
figured if we were gonna do a video
where Thor's hammer gets destroyed then
why not do a video where it gets
destroyed in like the most awesome way
possible which is the God blast we've
never talked about the God blast before
and it's a really cool concept in the
realm of Marvel Comics in the sense that
it basically deals with the idea of just
how powerful Thor can be in terms of the
absolute peak of his abilities for the
most part now the cool thing about this
is that this actually picks up as a
two-part story of sorts in Thor issues
387 actually is a three part Thor issues
387 388 and 389 from the first volume
now the cool thing about this is Thor
initially just kind of wakes up out in
the middle of nowhere he was
transporting from Asgard
I believe this came as a fallout with
his battle against a villain called Seth
who's one of those weird gods that
exists out there Arnall thing is really
that important but in the middle of all
this he wakes up using his hammer to fly
back ends up on a planet called Pan
gorya now Pan gorya is effectively
war-torn I mean this is a planet worse
like this military regime there's
effectively running the show and is led
by a guy named Vegas who's really one of
the cruelest people that I think we've
seen in the history of Marvel just by
virtue of what he does but the fact that
they're Ward's warrant and the fact that
their warring against one another is
actually pretty significant and the
reason why is because once Thor arrives
here starts poking around is basically
rescued after he crash-lands and begins
to get the lay of the land where he
intends to basically intervene and
effectively defeat the bad guys the
entire planet is met by the arrival of
air Ashima the judge of the Celestials
now the arrival of the Celestials is a
pretty big deal and if you guys are you
know familiar with this you know with
air sham and so on then bear with me for
a second because there's a lot of people
who aren't in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we had like ego the Living
Planet who was deemed a celestial my
argument is that the Grandmaster will
probably be a celestial the Marvel
Cinematic Universe interpretation of
Celestials is radically different than
the version of Celestials from the main
Marvel comics in Marvel Comics the
Celestials are just these beings who are
extremely old and depending on what era
of Marvel Comics you're reading the
Celestials role in the Marvel Universe
will basically fluctuate and it will
change if for example
we go back to the extremely old stories
with like the arrival of the fourth host
and different things like that but
Celestials are just some of the oldest
beings in existence and somewhere along
the line they basically cast off their
corporeal form they became beings of
pure energy so technologically advanced
that they were effectively gods if you
read a little further in the Marvel
comics if you jump forward a couple of
decades like with x-men I'd maybe was
new x-men Marvel establishes that the
Celestials basically were the ones who
were responsible for the creation of all
space and time and created the
multiverse if you read all-new
all-different marvel the Celestials were
one of two races that existed at the
beginning of all things alongside the
aspirants and their civil war led to the
destruction of the first reality which
coalesced into the multiverse and just
sort of dying then repeating over and
over again there have been different
interpretations of how the Celestials
function within the Marvel Universe
because different writers just take
different liberties what we can take
away from the various iterations of the
Celestials in Marvel Comics is they are
this you know almost unstoppable force
but the Celestials are sort of
experimenters they are people who travel
around and they basically create life on
new worlds for example on earth they
created the mutants deviants and they
created the Eternals things like that
but the idea is that when the Celestials
conduct this experiment they basically
come back every so often in the form of
a host so a host is a term that can be
used interchangeably with an arrival you
know in inspection something along those
lines if the Celestials show up and they
find out the experiment is not
progressing like it's supposed to which
is to say that the race they created has
basically just stayed primitive they
never technologically evolved or
anything like that the Celestials will
basically wipe out all things in
existence and this comes in two forms
with this particular story the arrival
of arish and the judge is basically just
showing up and simply saying okay we
have analyzed this planet for the last
50 years we've looked at how they've
evolved we've looked at what they're
probably going to become and we have
deemed them to be unworthy and that's
where you get the thumbs down it's
basically this race is not fit to exist
we're going to eliminate them in their
entirety and no one can really stop them
I mean the Celestials are just so
stoppable I mean they're they're so
incredibly powerful now in this moment
and in this conflict where Thor does
what he can to sort of stem off heirship
there's nothing he can do I mean he just
doesn't have the power to hold a being
of this magnitude off well the various
members of this planet try to escape and
hey guess who's basically
kind of a dick leaves his folks behind
again Thor tries to hold off against
Irish Jim but it's really just sort of a
lost cause not only that in the middle
of his attack he's basically met with
the arrival of exits hard the
exterminator now this is kind of a big
deal because we're ere Jim the judge
stands at around 2,000 feet tall exit
our stands at around 20,000 feet tall
and exit our is basically the one that
shows up and eliminates everything now
the cool thing about this is it also
gives us some insight into how the
Celestials function which is to say what
their makeup is how their energy works
different things like that and in this
scenario because of the fact that egg
the coming of exit R means this planet
has a ticking clock which is maybe a
minute or two before the entire place
comes crashing down
Thor races up to the top of exit arc and
manages to punch a hole in his armor and
then climb through but notice this
that's the extent of the damage he does
he punches a hole through his armor
Thor's ability to damage exit R is
equivalent to you trying to destroy your
house by walking up and punching a hole
in the wall that's the most you could
possibly do now once the word gets
inside this is when we start to get into
the interesting concept of what
Celestials are made up of but remember
we have to take this story for what it's
worth as you know in the sense that it's
basically self-contained we cannot treat
what we see here as an absolute fact but
within exit R the exterminator is just
like this amalgamation of all these
different energies and all these
different organisms in these different
monsters and so it almost seems like
exit r is a ecosystem unto itself and
even within you know exit r itself are
like planets solar systems things like
that again nothing on par with a
universe but it does house its own
organisms there is life living inside of
exit R that's why it's kind of cool here
is because in this instance Thor
basically begins to realize how
overpowered and outmatched he is against
such a force but it still goes back to
the roots of Thor in the sense that he
doesn't give up he never really quits
now the whole idea behind this is that
Thor finally locates what amounts to the
brain of exit R and that's when things
begin to get a little weird here is
because with the character of exit R one
of the things that was established when
it came to Fantastic Four issue number
400 which I believed was written by a
Tom DeFalco was this idea that the
concept of exit are basically being the
being that goes through and eliminates
life on on the civil planets how
to always exist there has to always be
an exit our if this exit our is
destroyed another will always take its
place so you know with or going into the
mind of exit are basically and
encountering what amounts to this giant
humanoid which is a security guard of
sorts after it's destroyed Thor destroys
the mind of exit art but the way in
which Thor destroys the mind of exit art
is crazy because this is effectively the
God blast now the way that it's
explained to us the way the God blast is
given to us in this story is that it's
not just like Thor hitting something
really really hard
it's basically channeling everything
that makes Thor who he is is effectively
grabbing his life and throwing it into
the hammer now the reason why this
matters is because one of the big
misconceptions with Thor is that he is
an Asgardian and that's where it stops
that's not actually true Thor is an
Asgardian and an elder God hybrid which
is to say he's from Asgard which is an
extra dimensional plane but he's also
the son of Gaia who is an elder god that
represents the very existence of earth
represents mother earth more or less
when it comes to Marvel Comics you have
all manner of gods to religious gods so
like Onan is a religious God and you
know Zeus is a religious God and like
Vishnu and Yahweh and things like that
they represent the pantheon of the sky
fathers and then you have your
respective gods under then you've got
Loki and you've got Thor and you've got
SIF and you've got you know ball to the
brave under Odin and Zeus you've got
like Hercules and different things like
that and then you have other gods who
are considered to be elder gods which
are basically just these entities that
came into existence at the very
beginning of the Earth's formation now a
lot of these elder gods were either
destroyed in the Civil War of the other
gods or if they didn't they escaped
earth and took off into other dimensions
so like Sid Iraq for example who gave
juggernaut his powers more or less took
off to another dimension called the
Crimson dimension and you've got a lot
of those different beings who exist out
there
Gaia remained on earth and so because of
this Thor is the son of an elder God and
the son of an Asgardian and what it does
is it gives him heightened strength and
durability beyond what a normal ass
guardian is capable of that's why he's
so powerful but in this instance and
this is kind of a weird thing here
there's also something called the belt
of strength
now the belt of strength and I'll even
know how to pronounce this this phrase
but the belt of strength is actually
this artifact that originally appeared
in journey into mystery number 91 and
was created by Jack Kirby and dick Ayers
I think it was and the whole idea behind
this is that it is a belt that
effectively doubles the strength of Thor
the caveat to this is that when Dan
Jergens was writing the Thor stories
after the events of heroes reborn which
was more or less a soft reboot for the
Thor character in for volume 2 issue
number 25 in 2000 the belt was seen for
like the last time when Thor flawed a
nose and then it was gone the belt
hasn't been seen or heard from since at
the time the story's written however the
belt does exist the belt is still there
and so in this instance Thor basically
takes the belt in wraps it around my own
ear doubling the strength of what it's
capable of and also helping to sort of
channel all the energies it'll let off
and then he in turn takes all his
energies his lifeforce and then channels
it directly into the hammer and when he
does he basically smashes the brain of
exit are not only that because of the
massive amount of energy that's led out
of this thing it basically shatters his
own hammer it's an insane amount of
energy what it also does is it gives us
a limitation of what it is that Thor's
Hammer's capable of the idea of the
hammer having so much energy channeled
into it that it effectively
explodes is something that I don't think
we've really seen before and so again
that's why this is so cool now of course
this basically leads to the idea that
the judge of airship is still gonna go
through the judgment of this plane of
destruction is going to happen and the
way in which this takes place it's
actually kind of cool when it comes to
the Celestials because they are so
powerful they have something called
cosmic awareness and what cosmic
awareness does is it allows an
individual that has it or God that has
it to basically know everything that's
going around in the universe are going
on in the universe at any particular
moment no matter what it is or what's
happening from the smallest thing all
the way up to the largest thing now with
Celestials having cosmic awareness and
because these judgments are designed to
basically purge all life on any one
particular planet if a person were to
leave a planet and the Celestials deem
that planet to be unworthy of continuing
to live they would eradicate every
member of that race no matter where they
are and that's kind of the cool thing
about that we've seen that on a few
occasions when it comes to Marvel Comics
but in this instance those individuals
who were trying to make their escape
explicitly play off Vegas
getting destroyed by Irish and the judge
now of course once floor makes his
escape from the interior of exit our
once exit our is gone effectively shut
down this ultimately leads to era sham
intervening in the sense that airship is
the one that you know goes through and
obliterates all things at the same time
it is this analysis of Thor in terms of
why it was that he did what he did and
in this scenario it makes sense because
if Thor had just destroyed exit art he
was like I do it because I want absolute
power then he would have just been
obliterated by the Celestials but the
fact that he was doing it because he was
trying to preserve life on this planet
and didn't really understand what the
motivations of the Celestials were or at
the very least didn't believe that all
life on his planet actually needed to
die because he was effectively being uh
being a good guy what is it happening is
they don't eradicate him instead they
create this sort of humanoid copy which
is to say somebody that can speak on
behalf of the Celestials since they
never actually speak themselves and what
this humanoid construct basically says
is hey look man the Celestials get that
you are trying to do a good thing you
were trying to be a good guy don't
intervene again because if you do you're
gonna die the first time is
understandable the second time you just
piss and folks off and that's not okay
so of course this leads to Thor's hammer
being restored his suit basically being
returned to him and he just goes about
his business being a superhero but it is
kind of a cool moment here because again
this basically just stands as the idea
that Thor is exceedingly powerful in
terms of what he's capable of what is
something like the God blast if is
powerful enough to destroy what amounts
to a celestial that's more powerful than
Galactus imagine what it would do
against Idol actists like a planet or
something along those lines it's a level
of power that Thor almost never uses
because if he did it would obliterate
whoever it is he's fighting on whatever
planet it is that he's fighting on so
again that's why things get kind of
crazy is because within exit targets
self-contained is contained within the
exit our entity but if you were to use
the god blasts on the Incredible Hulk
for example I would wager the amount of
energy let off by that thing would
probably obliterate the planet I mean
it's it's insane amount of power but
with that being said guys figured I'd
bring you this cool little story where
you guys get to see the really one of
the most powerful maneuvers that Thor
uses again we don't see you that often I
wish we did
cuz it'd be kind of cool to see but with
that being said we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain and make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb court if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you
a link and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]